alexander kolesnikov carefully lays out
the postcards his daughter maria
sends him from jail he knows she writes
to him every day
and that only some come through this
month none at all
[Music]
foreign
here on the right is a fighter she's one
of the trio of women who ran against
alexander lukashenko
in last august's presidential elections
and famously ripped up her passport
rather than be forced into exile
[Applause]
now she faces charges of creating an
extremist organization
and a possible 20 years in jail
other prisoners have written to her
father to tell him that she's an
inspiration to them
[Music]
and
[Music]
letters from the outside kept levon
kalatrian going in the six months that
he spent in pre-trial detention
this was the moment he was reunited with
his son
the little boy is shy not sure how to
react to the father he hasn't seen for
so long
this freedom is short-lived though will
soon start two years labor in an
open facility all just for working on
the campaign
of one of lukashenko's rivals
[Music]
um
the protest movement has fizzled over
the winter as the regime tightens its
grip
daria losing's husband ihar is a 28 year
old blogger
he has just finished a second hunger
strike and has tried to slit his wrists
his letters are filled with despair
mr
but she still comes with food every
thursday and she says it's clear what
the international community
should do
but so far sanctions have not persuaded
lukashenko to open the doors of his
jails
or to do what the majority of his people
want
end a 26-year dictatorship which has
become
ever more cruel